هنا باب العمود اضخم البوابات الرئيسيه
للبلده القديمه بالقدس بارتفاع يبلغ
ثمانيه امتار
ام ثراء من حيث الزخارف ويعود اسمه الى
الفتره الرومانيه حيث تم وضع عمود من
الرخام الاسود يصل ارتفاعه ضعف ارتفاع
الباب في الساحه الداخليه وتم استخدام
العمود كاداه لقياس بعد مسافات الدول
والمدن عن مدينه القدس وللباب اسم اخر اقل
تداولا هو باب دمشق لانه كان الباب الذي
تخرج منه القوافل التجاريه الى دمشق
وللباب اجواء رمضانيه خاصه حيث يتزين
بالاضواء والفوانيس ويتوافد عشرات الالاف
من المسلمين للدخول من هذا الباب وصولا
للمسجد الاقصى ويجلس المئات على درجات باب
العمود لتناول الحلويات بعد الافطار من
البسطات او حتى لتناول وجبه السحور قبل
الفجر لا نقول غاصي من القدس العربيه